okay let's go to our next caller from
the 408 area code 408 go ahead I
actually had a question regarding Israel
okay do you think it's do you think it's
unfair despite sort of the
disproportionate condemnation Israel
gets from the UN when countries like
Saudi Arabia and China are not
criticized that despite all of that that
it is still valid to say that Israel
isn't a great ally of the United States
and in in the sense of that their their
interests don't really coincide with
that of the the US I mean if you sort of
look at you know I mean a lot of sort of
government officials and intelligence
people some of some of whom that I think
you've had on your show like Lawrence
Wilkerson basically allude to the fact
that you know whether it's you talk
about sort of the attack on the USS
Liberty in 67 or sort of what they
believe to be is Israeli
you know coordination potentially with
even Sunni extremists in Syria to fight
off the Iranians or ultimately their
that they're they're not really even
although you know obviously that you can
clearly say that the neighboring
countries of Israel are far more odious
factor certainly in the way that they
treat their own people but that Israel
in itself is still not really a credible
ally in terms of that you know I mean
maybe the relationship isn't a symbiotic
as some of our politicians try to make
it seem as it is that otherwise yeah
it's I mean so so let's think about it
right
Saudi Arabia for example Saudi Arabia is
a completely deplorable authoritarian
theocracy they behead people in the
streets so on and so forth but they
share American interests in Middle
Eastern stability in order to protect
the oil flows we sell them weapons so on
and so forth is Saudi Arabia really a
great ally of the United States not
ideologically except for the fact that
you do have a lot of these
Christian theocrats who seemed to have
no problem doing deals with Saudi Arabia
which just has a Muslim version of the
same Christian theocracy that these
right-wing ideologues would like so you
can it depends on how you evaluate the
Alliance so now let's talk about Israel
in the same way that the United States
and Saudi Arabia have this interest of
stability in the Middle East the US and
Israel also share that interest now
because of the perverted right wing
Netanyahu regime which has no interest
in peace whatsoever you would
immediately say well if the US wants
Middle East peace and Benjamin Netanyahu
clearly doesn't because you wouldn't
benefit from it and in fact he runs his
campaigns on the idea that he alone will
keep you safe that all of a sudden
doesn't actually seem like a great
alliance so I think what you're bringing
up is completely reasonable I just think
you have to think a little more deeply
about what we mean when we say alliances
does the u.s. look the other way to
Saudi beheadings because of the shared
interest in stability yes they do does
the u.s. look the other way about the
reality that Benjamin Netanyahu is not a
credible arbiter of peace because of a
lot of other reasons which we could talk
about yes they do but we just sort of
have to understand how these alliances
are built geopolitically right right
that yeah I mean I think ultimately
although more people are willing to
concede the fact that the Saudis are
clearly not good allies but I guess that
that's more to do with the fact that
it's pretty transparent al you know I
mean there there you might be the most
you know her oppressive regime in the
world maybe outside of North Korea but I
guess maybe that have to do it yeah
appreciate you very much yeah thank you
so much and on that note we are out of
time if we didn't get to you I apologize
but we will take calls again next week
quick break back after this